uh we learned late last night about a
major change to the scope
of the current new york attorney
general's investigation
into the trump organization it is now a
criminal investigation full stop
what started as a civil investigation
into the trump organization
is now a criminal investigation this is
a huge deal
and it at least changes the possible
path
of the probe now remember that new york
state attorney general
leticia james was already in the middle
of a civil investigation of donald
trump's company
now they are investigating the trump
organization quote
in a criminal capacity this is also
it's hard to even keep this all straight
this is not the same investigation that
sy vance jr is doing
james's spokesman says this
investigation is being conducted
in conjunction with the criminal probe
of trump and the trump organization by
the manhattan district attorney cyrus
vance
this is the attorney general of new york
now these are two criminal
investigations now
part of this is all thanks to michael
cohen donald trump's former attorney
who has said many times now that the
trump organization
misstated real estate valuations to
reduce their tax liabilities
and to get better loan and insurance
terms the full statement from
leticia james's office is short and it
is quote we have informed the trump
organization
that our investigation into the
organization is no longer purely civil
in nature we are now actively
investigating the trump organization in
a criminal capacity
along with the manhattan district
attorney we have no
additional comment at this time recall
that leticia james
is the prosecutor who went after the
trump foundation
trump's now dissolved charity was
ordered
to pay two million dollars to settle a
lawsuit by the ag's office saying he
misused
the trump foundation uh and its funds to
benefit his presidential campaign as
well as other unlawful activity for more
than a decade and the trump foundation
agreed to pay the fine
and they also agreed in december of 2018
to completely dissolve
and donate all remaining funds to
charity that's the same
leticia james that got that done
who is now investigating the trump
organization criminally
trump is calling both investigations
witch hunts which to me suggests wow
there's probably something here
and we will see where both
investigations go now i maintain
and i know some people get mad when i
say this i maintain
trump will see no prison time period
there will be no handcuffed perp walk
but the more that this builds and now it
has shifted from merely civil to
criminal
the possibility that someone goes to
prison does go up but almost certainly
this is going to be a massive financial
burden on trump
in terms of legal bills and as i've said
before
these investigations while they're not
going to put trump in prison
they're not they could keep trump from
running in 2024 which would be amazing
it's optimistic thinking but uh
it very well could quickly become a
massive burden for trump and if it keeps
him out of
out of candidacy in uh three and a half
years that would be a great thing now
there's one other
aspect to this there are people reacting
to news from this probe and from the sci
vance probe by saying
if it's taking this long nothing is
happening it's just going to peter out
i spoke to a couple of prosecutors i
know who said
you know from the outside you can't
really know
but often the longer the investigation
takes the stronger the case is because
they're uncovering more and more
wrongdoing
and they want to be really sure that the
cases are iron-clad before they move
forward
either way it's speculative but the
point is it's not
obvious it's not certain that the fact
that this is dragging with no charges
yet
is bad um it's also important to
remember at least with the
vance probe that trump was able to
obstruct
that moving forward by not providing his
tax returns
for his entire presidency only in the
last couple of months
did they finally get a court decision
that said yes trump must give saivans
his taxes
so that part of the investigation has
only really now started it's been
delayed and that could be part of it as
well
one other really small thing a couple of
people wrote to me and they said
this is the real reason trump left new
york it wasn't to avoid taxes it wasn't
because
new york wasn't good to him because they
didn't vote for him in the presidential
election the real reason trump left new
york was to get away from this
investigation
i just don't think so number one trump
is a narcissist
and narcissists have this idea that no
one can touch them
so i don't think trump is leaving that
doesn't make sense number two
leaving new york doesn't actually stop
the investigations
so it would be stupid in that sense and
number three
trump is really cheap and really greedy
so
leaving changing residency from new york
to florida
makes a lot of sense because avoiding
taxes is completely on
brand with donald trump's priorities so
that's i believe that's really the
reason trump
left the investigation will follow him
to florida if that's what needs to
happen
and um it will um
uh trump i don't think trump really
thinks in the terms you and i might
think
of something like this so i think it's
just money and that's why trump left
new york at least as far as residency is
concerned we'll have
more on this growing multiple
investigations set now
on the david pakman show instagram make
sure you're following us on instagram at
davidpakmanshow
and follow me on instagram for the
latest from my
garden nothing more riveting than that
you can find me on instagram at
david.pakman
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wristwatch is the
perfect way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my vincero watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy
and five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman